[музика]
дихайте 630 депутати бундестагу убихи
цейсередній клас викладок або каррі
і юристи навіть душ бухті те що в ньому
дуже еномай засіли багатіїв віку прийшли
з бізнесу політику яхти часто буває в
україні думаю тут практичні скандали
фанат прибудуть до них через монети
депутатів шини вигляд бачу їх ним
доходом наживатися на політати і в ньому
дуже і практично на миші його ios чому
зарубає на сукні купити і на зарплату
німецьких депутатів але не становить
9 тисяч євро нами мережа в вона однак для
всіх депутати бундестагу крем того
депутати відривати у вузько 4000 євро на
дадуть ви витрачені кави за крима на офіс
роботу в округах.
пелих і видні на вигляд українських
депутатів німецька є чисельних
пінг на прокат на санаторному обличчі
їх не пінгу втечі безкоштовно борошно
виткам і на коліях черв'я так назвали
президента бундестагу
також депутати дуже не в низьких
до пенсійного фонду та від кави доходи
заданим і transparency international
моєю шкірою 4 депутат про крем плід не в
бундестагу
травня йдуть від копія плям і над хоч дружина
зазвучати депутати засідають на готових
пологах компанії мають консалтингові
послухай вину за в'язані на дату
повною викреслю інформацію про той від
кого разом роботи та рій будуть of team
декларація про доходи
депутати мати в казату приблизно суму
доході за машину парламенту за
системою категорії
дпш категорія дусі до трьох з половиною
тисячі євро на місяць а 10 менше 200 50
тисяч євро зазвичай ці заробітки
депутатів мишах інший ч 3 категорії
свою юрич нападуть на кого декларацію
депутата мати піддаватися президенту
бундестагу через мову в витрачанні
репутацію
депутата на махайте світлоту на годину
частина але
подарунки депутат травня за видами це
президента бундестагу впроси подарунки
у artistic їх перевищив 200 euro win
такий же травня перед президентом
бундестагу упси подарунки
від риму не печа служба ви ідеальний
steam вельможі за вишиті подарована кліше
в тому й рази як що компасу і впадуть копій
повний його vortice донорський у мисці
член бундестагу травня укри марафонах 2
донорських грушевих всю
проблиску суму японок 5 тисяч євро
проти одного календарного уроку
вин травня за видами це президента бунт
статуту разом з іменним та адреса уідон ура
я хочу сума в мисці виду того донора
вище в цьому тесті тисяч євро за 1 рік
процес буду знову і на розголошена
на сайті бундестагу ніж у німців та на
США
німецькі парламентарії до потрібно
закону та кодексу щодо wedding та депутата
через страх втрати дасу спину ютуберу то
на потрап це в список своєї партії на
доступних виборах наведеної миші
розкрито куртини дії в ньому а че не
нам і ніч залишилася коробка на
політичній кар'єрі